all right it appears President Trump is
going to take a brief hiatus in his
criticism of Robert molars witch-hunt
the president tweeted earlier I'm headed
to Canada for the g7 for talks that will
mostly sent her on the longtime unfair
trade practices against the United
States from there I go to Singapore and
talks with North Korea on the
nuclearization of course of the Korean
Peninsula I won't be talking about the
Russia witch-hunt hoax for a while here
was reaction to the upcoming IG report
and Muller's ongoing which on former
Clinton pollster and advisor mark Penn
Attorney Victoria tun Singh David
Limbaugh well I got to say about David
and Victoria and pretty much everybody
they I have the best lawyers in the
world they've done legal work for me
because if I don't say it every time the
left-wing media has a heart attack over
nothing but good to see you all David
Limbaugh let me start with you
we know crimes were committed here now
the president is moving into real the
opportunity to make some significant
changes that will impact the entire
world our kids and grandkids but the
witch hunt continues smart of him to
just let it go for a while yeah I think
that the media will never let it go and
Trump can re-enter the fray any time he
wants to I think people have
underestimated Trump on foreign policy
and treat him as a comic book player I I
admit I'm surprised that he is as good
as he is you know when he made that
comment foreign policy I mean when he
made that comment about not preparing
what he meant was he has negotiated all
his life he didn't mean he wasn't going
to bone up on North Korea South Korea
and US history
and you know I assume he said it's a
very seasoned life
yeah and he's he's look at the way he's
a realist he's willing to walk away look
how calm he is he doesn't when he when
he belittles Rocketman when he needs to
but otherwise he's very serious and he's
enticed him I think Trump is seen as a
capitalist yeah I think Kim jong-un is
worse shape than he's ever been in and
he's enticed by the prospect of China
and the United States
his dark dark countries he started to
purge some of the old holdovers that you
know would be so rigid against change
let me go to the IG report another big
story and look you're a longtime Clinton
pollster mark you've you've been there
you've been critical David and Victoria
will tell you that Hillary violated
multiple laws server literally having
top-secret classified special access
program information on an unsub is
handle that destroyed it cover it up
obstructed after subpoena deletions and
all that do you agree with that because
that's what I think that we know the
truth that that's what the IG should say
how do you feel about it I work for them
so long you know
first let me say on the on the eve of
these of these summits III hope the
president will have disciplined with his
Twitter account
I hope Giuliani will have disciplined I
hope Schumer and Pelosi will have
disciplined so that we as a country
speak with one voice against a dictator
for something that can affect all of our
children for a couple of days and I
think it will require that kind of
discipline now when this report comes
out a couple of days later this report
is actually not going to be about the
Clintons it is not going to be about
whether the Clintons are leaders oh that
was it handled or mishandled well yes
but it's really about whether the FBI
did its job properly or improperly
that's what this reports going to be
about and I think that's what we're
gonna have to take away from this
because that will tell us if they didn't
carry out that investigation fairly what
makes you think that they carried out
the Trump Russia investigation from you
being critical as a Democrat and I got
to give you credit because this is bad
for the country and this can't stand
fight you know because I think our
Constitution is being stepped on Sean
and we really have to be on guard here
that presidents can do their job without
the constant threat of investigations
for everybody in their administration
for everybody in the campaign that go on
without and because I can tell you I've
been there I was with the president in
ninety
did not help the country that we wasted
a year on that it did not help the
country that we wasted a year on this
and then we shouldn't be wasting another
year in the absence of really compelling
evidence which we have not been any
respect seen let me go to your Victoria
I think the evidence is incontrovertible
the mark is right there what we'll deal
mostly with the investigation but their
war underlying crimes the facts are not
even in dispute James Comey laid them
out two days after they interviewed
Hilary but they were writing the
exoneration months before what do you
expect and how should this be handled if
in fact crimes were committed and then
the investigation ranked well Sean I'm
gonna tell you what I'm more concerned
about is this trunk collusion
investigation that's just a mockery and
how the Republicans are failing us the
Republicans in Congress are not doing
their job I have some very good sources
and let me tell you that speaker Ryan
and trey Gowdy decided that it was not
in the moderates of the Republicans
moderates interests for the fall
election - there was bad politics to be
at odds with the Justice Department and
the Democrats on the 2016 election so
they decided they were going to tamp it
down and when trey Gowdy came on Fox and
said well when the FBI heard what they
heard then they they did exactly what we
all hope they would do know he was he
was tamping it down and they were not
doing what we hope they do because they
did not follow protocol they are
supposed to go to the American and say
hey do you know that you're being
targeted by the Russians but not only
that trey Gowdy said that without any
other knowledge whatsoever and you know
do you know why Sean because they
haven't gotten the documents yeah and
and guess what happened yesterday they
were supposed to be delivered the
documents by DOJ and they got snookered
because the DOJ backed off and they
backed off why did they do it because
they want to put him out next week when
we have the they wanted to be buried
with the IG report the Republicans got
snookered being nice just like you said
you can't suck up to your adversaries
good to see you all thank you important
information from all of you